this is the group responsible for
hacking two of the biggest computing
companies in the world and stopping more
than a hundred and fifty million people
from playing their games consoles this
Christmas the group calling themselves
lizard squad attacked Sony and Microsoft
closing down online services speaking to
us from Finland this man who calls
himself Ryan says he is one of the
hackers he claims the hack only took a
few members and the youngest was just 13
years old there's the core members which
is about three or four people who
actually perpetrated their tax and then
there's various other people involved
doing various other things but there's a
dag it was basically done by three
people why why did you do this it
affected so many people it ruined
Christmas for potentially millions of
people why we did it mostly for the
raise awareness do I measure ourselves
also one of the big aspects here was
raising awareness regarding the low
state of computer security at these
companies because these companies make
tens of millions every month from just
their subscriber fees and that doesn't
even include like purchases made by
their customers they should have more
than enough funding be able to protect
against these attacks you say that
you're doing it to make sure that people
understand the security or lack thereof
on these networks but you're laughing
when you're talking about it on the
Internet you obviously bragging about it
but this is a serious thing there are
victims to this aren't there the victims
I'd contrary the biggest within Sony and
Microsoft because they actually lost
money from this but how would they work
they won't lose money how would they
lose money they've already got their
members signed up paying a monthly
subscription to their service they're
not going to lose out are they um you're
gonna have to pay massive amounts of
money for a bandwidth we use for all the
traffic we sent them do you not feel
guilty that you've taken so much
enjoyment of gaming away from more than
a hundred million people over this
Christmas period I'd be rather worried
if those people didn't have anything
better to do than play games on their
consoles on Christmas Eve and Christmas
Day
I mean I can't really say I feel bad I
might have forced a couple of kids to
play spent their time with their
families instead of playing games the
hack took down systems on Christmas Day
it meant that gamers were unable to
download new games or access multiplayer
ones Xbox Live was restored within 24
hours but on the PlayStation Network
this was the error message that still
greeted some gamers today
Katy brought her boyfriend a ps4 for
Christmas it's still in its box
untouched and unplayed this was a
present for my boyfriend for Christmas
and obviously I'd saved up for a while
to get it I was really excited about it
he's wanted one for ages so and this was
my only present for him as well so it
was really disappointing to open it up
and then find out that we couldn't use
it or plug it in lizard squad is just
one of the many hacking groups all
fighting for notoriety online security
analyst Vinny Omari is well-connected to
the community he expects more hackers to
join in it's kind of like a school
playground where one guy gets involved
and then he gets his friends involved
and then someone else had come in just
to like back them up like anonymous the
finest squad and lizard squad other
three groups right now that are going
toe to toe are one another for the
hackers it's all just a game but for the
millions of people wanting to use their
consoles it's been a frustrating
Christmas they'll want to forget Joe
tidy Sky News